a big big fight and I mean really this
is no joke definitely not no Christy
giver was claiming she suffered a brain
injury as a result of the scuffle with
Tara Joel a stop by et to give us her
side of the story
you watch my video I'm not the liar
always a liar no and everybody ran up by
hi out of its stroke honestly it started
as a verbal discussion and then things
escalated to an unfortunate situation
unfortunate is an understanding watch
what happens next I got to tell you
something it's hard to watch it's
definitely difficult because I'm not
that person the January bar fight
captured by Mike Times little women are
like cameras sent people to the hospital
and yes are now investigator we made
friends were together I work out I can
win by my cowboy
it's in a situation that has changed my
life talk about that I can only say so
much because it's still under
investigation
and there was ice tea that I threw at
her but there were multiple things
thrown at me everybody gotta get hit by
the damn drinks you're saying it was
iced tea so it wasn't alcohol being
consumed there was no alcohol involved
in any of this it was more just emotions
being thrown around
but let's face it these la women don't
have a monopoly on catfights just ask
the Real Housewives of New Jersey or
Beverly Hills many reality shows there
have been many heated confrontations and
I wonder if there's any element of like
feeling pressure to amp up the drama the
root of it had nothing to do necessarily
with the reality side of it rather than
like our friendship have you ever
received direction or input from
producers on how they want you to behave
we were never ever told never a lot of
girls are a little bit intense
especially when it comes to like finding
who's the dominant female and I really
feel like that goes on in any group
setting of girl